ça va pas très années facile mais 23
mais on est dans la lignée de 2022 et je
vois une deuxième partie d'année très
mouvementée beaucoup de monde dans la
rue beaucoup de manifestations voilà je
pense que c'est une année un peu de
transition il n'y a pas être facile non
je vois pas une amélioration avant 2026
[Applaudissements]
il y a trois semaines que la France ne
gagnerait pas et j'ai annoncé aussi les
deux candidats ah oui oui les deux
candidates qui sont sortis sur Miss
France
alors on a des questions à vous poser
bien entendu par rapport aux
chroniqueurs déjà le chroniqueur qui
pose problème
est-ce que Benjamin Castaldi va trouver
ses 500000 euros non pas du tout est-ce
que Castaldi qu'est-ce que vous voyez
pour lui financièrement
donc ça va être quoi la vérité
je vois quand même pas cette année pour
moi quelque chose on s'améliorer
complètement
voilà après j'ai des nouveaux projets il
y a quelque chose sur les planches aussi
qui pourrait se mettre en place sur les
planches
à Deauville
et donc à des planches mais sinon son
année va être ça va ça va oui c'est une
année oui
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire quelque
chose sur sur Raymond Abou est-ce qu'il
va sortir de la dépression
alors moi c'est marrant parce que j'ai
quelque chose qui pourrait se mettre en
place et il y a peut-être un projet un
peu de d'audiovisuel cinéma télé il y a
quelque chose sachez que Canal+ qui fait
énormément de cinéma m'a appelé bon pour
savoir parce que
ils ont besoin de quelqu'un à l'accueil
[Applaudissements]
c'est possible
télévision
à quel moment je fais faire du cinéma
jamais c'est incroyable et encore
aujourd'hui j'ai reçu carrément les
textes de ce que je devais dire
j'ai pas dit oui j'ai pas dit que je
rappelle quand même à ceux qui nous
rejoignent qu'elle s'appelle Annabelle
about c'est la sœur de Raymond
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est fou alors c'est envoyé non non non
non non non non
non
ce qu'on voit vous êtes incroyable
Guillaume Genton
alors Guillaume Guillaume beaucoup de
sensibilité
[Rires]
moi c'est marrant parce que je sens
quelque chose comme si au niveau
sentimental il y a quelque chose qui est
fermé mais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bizarre
tout le temps beaucoup d'idées beaucoup
de créativité
aussi peut-être sur du reportage des
choses comme ça ouais c'est ce que je
dis on est sur un projet toile
je vous jure on est sur un projet de
production tous les deux c'est génial
c'est incroyable produire et tu vas être
gay
j'ai pas dit ça pour l'instant il a plus
de chance
[Applaudissements]
on terminera par les vraiment les
personnes les plus difficiles
c'est-à-dire Mathieu Gilles à la fin
hein bien entendu les personnes de
vraiment épineuses pour Daniel Moreau
est-ce qu'elle va déjà être vivante
toute l'année
oui oui
alors
moi je veux la santé de faire
il y a beaucoup d'humanité dans ce que
je ressens
il y a pour moi il y a un projet
d'écriture quelque chose sur un livre
des cartes postales
beaucoup mais je vois quelque chose de
nouveau une nouvelle un nouveau projet
écriture quelque chose qui est là alors
qui passe maintenant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la banane
[Rires]
on me dit pas pour le moment en tout cas
maintenant
[Rires]
Géraldine Géraldine a beaucoup de
sensibilités beaucoup d'intuitivité
[Musique]
je vois quelque chose quand même il y a
une capacité un don quelque chose aussi
par rapport
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas je vois pas mais pourquoi
c'est pas à une place peut-être
un ange gardien voilà
[Rires]
et donc vous voyez que c'est tout pas
grand chose
à côté de du monsieur il va faire du
cinéma
[Rires]
je me concentre un peu
juste à côté de Robert Redford
parce que je vois un Yara un changement
important par rapport à un projet aussi
qui peut être un projet
cinématographique ou quelque chose comme
ça
[Rires]
et on me parle aussi de l'étranger alors
il peut avoir une ouverture quelque
chose qui se fasse aussi bien à
l'étranger
c'est beau bah c'est pas mal
pour des choses
non j'en ai pas
l'enview
elle se trompe Raymond ça a été
incroyable ce que tu as dit
c'est incroyable
on va passer à ah oui avant les deux
années 2023
nouveaux projets des belles choses qui
se mettent en place et il y a une
émission animée
nouvelle émission en tant qu'animatrice
c'est pas sûr
[Rires]
ce que je vois un passage par rapport à
cette émission autre chose par derrière
un passage par derrière
ça s'appelle une double
[Applaudissements]
j'avais pas vu l'heure
il nous reste Mathieu Delormeau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors Mathieu
apparemment c'est épineux
oui alors Mathieu il y a une année pour
moi alors il y a beaucoup de projets qui
vont se mettre en place aussi sur cette
année 2023
et
[Musique]
là
25 ans mais pendant le concret non mais
dites-lui si vous avez des choses
difficiles à lui dire
c'est pas il y a pas de souci
[Rires]
pas du tout moi parfois ça arrive comme
ça il y a pas forcément
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
alors cinéma il peut avoir une ouverture
sur un investissement à l'étranger
à un moment donné
c'est compliqué pour lui alors
de Mykonos pour le projet à l'étranger
merci bah vous allez les dans le public
comme ça
c'est possible
alors il faut savoir qu'il a 88 ans
non je crois que c'est non
mais quand ça vient pas comme ça
qui doit se faire et qui se fait pas et
qui recule l'histoire de sa vie mais oui
c'est ça parce que je vois quelque chose
qui est en permanence comme si ça allait
se faire et pas ça se sépare exactement
et on arrive sur le point et oui ça ça
ne se fait pas mais oui ou pas je le
sens pas encore forcément cette année je
suis désolé je vous dis ce que je dois
te dire la vérité elle va pas te dire
des choses qui te font plaisir bien au
contraire c'est bien
mais je vois quand même un moment donné
le mariage qui va se mettre il va se
faire mais je n'ai pas encore tout de
suite peut-être pas avec vous voyez la
personne avec qui actuellement ou non
peut-être une autre alors
je sais pas je sens les choses
qui date déjà depuis un moment
finir ça
une relation c'est une relation vous
êtes très attaché à cette personne il y
a un lien très très fort de votre côté à
vous
alors
je sens qu'il y a aussi un lien qui est
fort qui est là mais qui a une peur
quelque part d'un engagement je pense
qui est compliqué par rapport à ça
j'ai une continuité mais c'est quelque
chose qui prend encore du temps je le
vois pas dans l'immédiat
et c'est même un mariage qui pourra se
faire c'est marrant j'ai quelque chose à
l'étranger oui mais est-ce que se marie
pas toute seule
mais très très festif oui à mon avis ça
sera sans lui alors
au moins au moins 500 personnes invitées
je vois vraiment une fête énorme quelque
chose mais je l'ai pas encore c'est
marrant je sais pas pourquoi j'ai pas
encore tout de suite là
alors
et sur Cyril
Mathieu vous voyez toujours rien non
est-ce que mathiasme très bien mais il
est pas bien Mathieu n'est pas bien
alors c'est l'avenir c'est incroyable
c'est incroyable franchement bravo à la
belle
au salon
Annabelle de Villiers
Espace Champerret Paris 17e
ça marche très super bien pour vous de
toute façon toujours en revanche je peux
avoir un petit peu de restructuration
peut-être sur des projets
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]